- Hey guys, it's Justine,
and today we're checking
out the Oculus Quest.
Now I am so excited about
this because I love VR,
but I don't like the process
to make a VR work, until now.
With Oculus Quest, you don't need a PC,
you don't need any wires,
everything you need is right in the box.
The experience of VR is so
much fun just to transport
yourself into another world.
A huge thank you to Oculus
for sponsoring this video.
I have been looking forward
to checking this out
since it was first announced.
Without further ado,
let's unbox, check it out
and then, I'm going to be going to E3
to be playing a demo
of the 360 Beat Saber game.
♪ Believer ♪
(gasps)
♪ Pain ♪
♪ You break me down ♪
♪ You build me up ♪
♪ Believer ♪
Dance Central, oh boy.
I'm gonna be getting my
workout in playing Oculus now.
(gasps)
Just like that.
The packaging is really well done.
It's super easy to set up
too because everything again
is in the box.
It also comes with the touch controllers.
This is what allows you to transport
your hands into the game.
That makes such a huge difference
being able to actually see your hands,
because it makes you feel
like you're so much more
in the environment.
I love that it also has this
feature called The Guardian.
So that'll allow you
to not run into things
when you're inside of the world.
Oculus inside tracking
system is right here.
So these are ultra-wide angle sensors.
It provides room scale tracking
without external sensors.
It's like we've got a charging brick
and this is a little extender,
if you have glasses, this will
allow you to wear glasses.
Hmm, this is a longer USB-C cable.
Got some batteries, those
are for the controllers.
Instructions, so little.
I'll read that later.
So the headset has built-in
audio, so you don't really need
a headset, but if you do
want to wear headphones,
there are two headphone
jacks on each side.
So there's one here and again right here.
It's gonna kinda be surrounding you,
so you'll be able to actually hear people
sneaking up behind you or
somebody in front of you
or to the left or to the right.
I think now is the time that we set it up.
This slides off very easily.
That's it.
In you go.
Do our setup.
Oculus Quest, now this
is gonna walk us through
and I am so ready!
It's updating, it's updating!
I guess I'll head off to
E3 to play Beat Saber 360,
so I'll see you guys in, right now.
(upbeat music)
We're about to go in the VR photo booth.
These look really funky.
(loud talking)
- [Photographer] Move over to the center,
so we're gonna do a few, don't worry,
we can kinda work it out.
- Oh, boy.
- [Photographer] We're
gonna slide you down, okay.
Two, three!
Nice!
- So we're not going to be playing
the Beat Saber 360 demo just yet.
First, we need to get
a photo for Instagram.
(mumbling)
- Maybe both.
- Okay.
- Jenna's on boom duty.
(upbeat music)
So now we're playing the demo.
I'm so excited about this.
It's really cool 'cause they
have two different levels
and they're both themed
around Imagine Dragons songs.
So you really think I should play on hard?
- Yes ma'am.
- Here we go.
This is gonna be so fun.
- Headphones in front of you.
- Let's go.
Okay, we're on hard.
Oh my, it's going so fast!
(bass music)
What did you do to me?
(upbeat music)
♪ First things first ♪
♪ Ima say all the words ♪
- Oh my gosh, this is insane.
♪ I'm fired up and tired of
the way that things have been ♪
- No, I did it wrong.
♪ The way that things have been oh ooh ♪
- Oh my God, there is so much happening.
♪ Don't you tell me what you think-- ♪
- It's slowing down a little.
No it's not, no it's not!
♪ You made me a believer ♪
- Ah!
♪ Pain ♪
♪ You break me down, ♪
♪ You build me up ♪
♪ Believer ♪
- Oh my gosh, it's a wall!
♪ Pain ♪
♪ I let the bullets fly ♪
♪ Oh let them rain ♪
♪ My luck ♪
- This is incredible.
♪ They came from ♪
♪ Believer ♪
♪ Pain ♪
♪ You break me down ♪
♪ You build me up ♪
♪ Believer ♪
♪ But they never did ♪
♪ Ever lived-- ♪
- What, no!
There are so many walls!
♪ Till it broke open and it rained down ♪
♪ It rained down ♪
♪ Like ♪
♪ Pain ♪
- Holy moly, you can't be,
you can't be doing this.
♪ Believer ♪
♪ You made me a believer ♪
- No way, we're back.
Oh gosh, the 360 is real.
♪ Pain ♪
♪ I let the bullets fly ♪
♪ Oh let them rain ♪
♪ My luck, my love, my God ♪
♪ They came from ♪
♪ Pain ♪
♪ You made me a, you made me a believer ♪
♪ Believer ♪
- Oh my gosh.
I did it.
That was so fun.
Okay let's do another one.
Okay so I got a D.
I think I might need to
practice a little bit.
Okay, Thunder.
♪ Leave my old life behind ♪
- So Thunder only has a hard option.
- [Man] Yes ma'am.
- Oh shoot, let's go.
Oh my gosh.
♪ Just a young gun ♪
♪ With a quick fuse ♪
♪ I was uptight ♪
♪ Wanna let loose ♪
♪ I was dreaming of bigger things and ♪
- Oh my gosh, this is so fast.
Nope.
♪ Not a yes sir ♪
♪ Not a follower ♪
♪ Fit the box ♪
♪ Fit the mold ♪
♪ Have a seat in the foyer ♪
- Oops!
♪ Take a number ♪
- Shoot.
Ah Come on, I'm not doing well.
This one is so hard.
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ Thun-thun-Thunder ♪
- Oh my gosh.
These walls are terrifying.
♪ Lightning and the Thunder ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ Feel the Thunder ♪
♪ Lightning ♪
♪ Thun-thun-thunder ♪
♪ Thunder ♪
♪ Thunder, thun- ♪
- Oh my gosh, there are walls everywhere.
♪ Thunder ♪
- (gasps) Okay, so I definitely,
didn't do as well as the last.
I still got a D.
That's not last in the alphabet.
That was so much fun.
Oh my gosh.
I think need to practice a little bit.
I'm sweating.
Well thank you guys so much
for watching, I had so much fun
playing Beat Saber 360 game.
It was honestly insane.
Like if you guys have
played the first one,
this was like a whole nother experience.
A huge thank you for Oculus
for partnering with me
on this video.
I had so much fun.
What I'd like to know from you guys
is would you like to
see me do more VR stuff,
like should I get a green screen wall
and really get crazy?
Let me know in the comments below.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye.
(upbeat music)